THE U.S.
LAURA.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, JEFF,
THANKS.
WHAT ABOUT THE AGENTS INVOLVED?
IS ANYONE TELLING THEIR STORIES?
IMAGINE IF A MASS OF HUMANITY
CHARGE AT YOU.
WANTING TO ENTER YOUR HOME.
MAYBE COME LIVE WITH YOU FOR A
WHILE.
THROWING ROCKS AND WAVING OTHER
COUNTRIES FLAG.
WELL, WHILE THE AGENTS
THEMSELVES AREN'T ABLE TO SPEAK
OUT OF THE MOMENT, THEY ARE
ALLOWED TO TALK WITH THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES, AND ONE JOINS
US NOW TO SHARE WHAT HE HAS
LEARNED.
HECTOR GARCIA IS A NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
PRESIDENT AND IS WITH US TONIGHT
FROM SAN ANTONIO.
HECTOR, WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE ON
YOUR TEAM TELLING YOU ON THE
GROUND?
YOU JUST SAW A REPORT ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED, ANOTHER VERY EMOTIONAL
WOMAN WHO SAYS THEY STARTED
THROWING TEARGAS CANISTERS AT
US.
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY WHAT
HAPPENED BUT THAT'S WHAT SHE
SAID.
WHAT DID THEY ENCOUNTER?
>> AGENTS WERE UNDER ATTACK.
THEY WERE ASSAULTED.
THESE MIGRANTS WERE THROWING
ROCKS.
THEY WERE THROWING GLASS
BOTTLES.
THEY WERE ALSO THROWING OTHER
DEBRIS IN THE AREA, AND IT'S A
MATTER FACT, SOME AGENTS WERE
HIT ON THEIR HELMETS WITH THESE
ROCKS.
MINOR INJURIES.
THERE WAS ALSO DAMAGE TO
VEHICLES AND WINDOWS WERE
BROKEN.
THIS WAS AN ASSAULT.
THIS WAS AN INVASION ON OUR
AGENTS, ON OUR COUNTRY.
OUR AGENTS HAD TO RESPOND WITH A
VERY LOW LEVEL OF FORCE, WHICH
IS THE TEARGAS THAT WAS
DEPLOYED.
>> Laura: NOW, WE HAD HEARD
FROM EVERYONE FROM MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO
GUATEMALAN OFFICIALS WHO SET
FROM THE BEGINNING THAT THE USE
OF WOMEN AND CHILDREN AT THE
FRONT OF THE LINES, WHETHER THEY
ARE CROSSING THE BRIDGE INTO
MEXICO FROM GUATEMALA OR
BREAKING THE BORDER INTO GUATEMA
FROM HONDURAS.
THAT THIS WAS DONE VERY
DELIBERATELY WITH CAREFUL
PLANNING.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CHILDREN HAD
FS CASUALTIES, THE ONES WHO
AREN'T TRAFFIC AND UP AS
CASUALTIES.
OR INJURED OR TRAUMATIZED.
BUT THEY WANT TO BLAME HECTOR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE I GUESS
THE BORDER SHOULD JUST BE OPEN
AND PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
COME IN 100 OF TIME AND FILL OUT
A FORM AND SAY I WANT ASYLUM.
>> THESE PEOPLE THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THE SAME THINGS THEY
DID ON THE GUATEMALA-MEXICO
BORDER, THEY ARE WRONG.
OUR AGENTS ARE PROPERLY TRAINED.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE USING
REASONABLE FORCE.
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE
REPORTING TO US THESE MIGRANTS
WERE USING THESE CHILDREN
AS HUMAN SHIELDS AND THEY WERE
LAUNCHING ROXETTE AGENTS.
THEY HAD NO REGARD FOR HUMAN
LIFE.
THEY DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE OTHER
MIGRANTS ARE THE KIDS.
OUR AGENTS TO DATE GREAT JOB BY
USING THE TEARGAS BY USING IT TO
DISPERSE THE CROWD.
THEY WERE JUSTIFIED TO USE A
HIGHER LEVEL OF FORCE BUT THEY
DID NOT.
THEY USE A LOW LEVEL OF FORCE
AND THEY WERE SUCCESSFUL.
THEY DID A GREAT JOB.
>> Laura: HECTOR, WHAT IF THE
NUMBERS INCREASE?
WHAT IF THEY SWELL?
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO KEEP
USING THE SAME STRATEGY.
THE GOOD THING IS WE HAVE THE
MILITARY AND THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID FOR US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DEPLOY
MORE RESOURCES TO THE AREA.
BUT IT IS GOING TO GET OUT OF
CONTROL AND THAT'S WHY CONGRESS
NEEDS TO ACT WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE DO BUILD THAT WALL SO
THAT WE CAN AVOID THESE TYPE OF
CONFRONTATIONS BECAUSE PEOPLE
WILL END UP GETTING HURT.
AGAIN, OUR AGENTS ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED AND THEY'RE GOING TO DO
THE BEST JOB THAT THEY CANNOT
THERE.
BUT AGAIN, THESE CARAVANS, THEY
NEED TO STOP.
WE NEED TO DO OUR JOB AND ALSO
MEXICO NEEDS TO DO THEIR JOB.
>> Laura: THEY SHOULD NEVER
HAVE BEEN TRUCKED TO THE BORDER.
MANY WERE TRUCKED UP.
THEY SHOULD NEVER BEEN ALLOWED
TO CROSS NEW MEXICO.
IS A SERIES OF THINGS IT HAD TO
HAPPEN FOR THIS SITUATION TO
RESOLVE IN THE CRISIS THAT IT IS
TODAY.
HECTOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE THINK THE BORDER PATROL
FOR US.
THEY ARE DOING INCREDIBLE WORK
UNDER VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES BEING MALIGNED BY
EVERYONE FROM HOLLYWOOD ACTORS
AND ACTRESSES WHO THEMSELVES --
HOW MANY IMMIGRANTS WITH A